[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter
hi martin
are you doing well
i'm a bit under the weather my i have a
frog in the throat but we'll get through
it is it a pet frog
no one no please no i don't want it for
a pet it can go now
okay
so we've got some interesting things
again let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father
it's a blessing to work for you and we
thank you dave for that we ask that you
bless the discussion and also enlighten
our minds once more
that we can put the prophetic picture
together we ask that in jesus name amen
amen
i see we both have
what do they call them jerseys pullovers
jumpers whatever language whatever
country you're in it's cold yeah no
today i also capitulated and i got
capitulated what does it say on that i
don't know unfortunately i never read
what's on these things so sometimes it
can get me into trouble so i don't think
you must read just i don't know what's
in on it or it just looks like a stamp
so i will refrain nothing bad
well we're going to talk about climate
change
hysteria
martin is there climate change hysteria
in the world
you know what the more i
see all this hysteria about the climate
going on the more i can see that people
are so deceived
yes
personally of course
i believe that they don't take
everything into account they don't take
chemtrails into account they don't take
harp technology into account they don't
take
supernatural activity into account
whatever you want to call there's more
than meets the eye
and i always find it so interesting that
they say you know this is the hottest
year forever and then you get an old
newspaper and it was just as hot 40
years ago
so you know what
no
it shows you that people have to start
realizing that's why
we we're like a broken record yes every
now we're carrying on on the same things
climate change digital identity all this
but it's it's if you repeat a lie often
enough
eventually people will start believing
it right and that's the the sad part
even the church
starts getting on the bandwagon and then
you're not
alert anymore or sensitive to see what's
going on correct and and if the church
gets onto that bandwagon particularly
our one you should say excuse me we have
a message to bear a three angels message
and this soapbox
is irrelevant except in the context of
the third angel's message
if if your message is in the context of
the third angel's message then fine but
if you're climbing onto the bandwagon
and joining the hysteria
when all the reputable climatologists
are saying this is a lot of nonsense
then i'm afraid then you've been
hoodwinked yeah because once you don't
see that part you won't be looking for
wasted deception
you'll just
take it as it is and oh this is just
part of what it should be yes so let's
look at some climate change hysteria i'm
really quite bored with it
but we're gonna be with it for quite a
while until the end until it finally
culminates in the third angel's message
that's it
and the lockdowns and the push for
sunday laws
martin how often have we read these
verses well i think it's a good idea to
know this whole chapter by
my heart well i think if we carry on
like this it should become a reality
pretty soon
nation shall rise against nation
kingdom against kingdom
famines pestilences earthquakes
and these are just the beginnings of
sorrows which means it gets worse
so the good news is it's going to get
worse
and so
coming back to what you said earlier
you should get used to this even if you
don't like it because we're going to be
sitting with this for a while yes
then shall they deliver you up to be
afflicted
and shall kill you it's when we get to
that point that we get into
into stress mode right and
we'll be seeing today again
are there talks are they
what was the
precursors during the last two years
of maybe telling you okay this is the
way that they might implement
these and you shall be hated of all
nations for my name's sake i think
they're doing a pretty good job on that
one already
and then shall many be offended and
shall betray one another and shall hate
one another
martin could this become a reality
within the church
i think it's already becoming irrelevant
don't go any further
and many false prophets shall arise and
shall deceive many
and because iniquity shall abound the
love of many shall wax cold
but
he that shall endure unto the end of the
same shall be saved you know that's
that's quite a heavy mouthful to swallow
right
at least there's a promise again
yes
yes there is there is a solution
so why are we doing this
because we have to be watchmen on the
walls of zion
and we have to see and identify
the approaching danger
martin here's an interesting article in
time
and it's by mariana matsukato
and you can give us a little low down on
her in a moment just to say that this
article was written in 2020
and it's almost like a
prophetic picture of
what she envisioned would happen
yeah she's very prominent in the economy
as a
advisor and all of those things and
she's a professor as well at um i think
london university also so she's
this can she she'll be part of those
that
may be in the know
okay
well to get an article into time
means that you have some profile yeah
so she is writing here in 2020 as if it
is 2023
and we're getting there pretty close
it's 2023.
here's how we fixed the global economy
the covet 19 pandemic has come to an end
well
that's prophetic because was written in
2020 right
it's funny
that she says it has come to an end but
the
legislation around it has not come to an
end
and the global economy is on the path to
recovery how did we get here how did our
economy and society evolve to overcome
the greatest crisis of our age let's
begin in the summer of 2020
when the unabated spread of disease was
heralding an increasingly dire outlook
for economic societies
it became clear that new policies were
needed to address climate risks
so that's a very first point
incentivize green lending scale up
financial institutions tackling social
and environmental goals and ban
financial sector activity that didn't
serve a clear public purpose
does that sound like the common good
that sounds like a common good and i
just wanted to say that that the
language is very similar to the pope
so yes
well maybe they all sat around the table
and contrived all of this terminology
on february 11 2021 the fda approved the
most promising covert 19 vaccine for
manufacture in the u.s mass production
began immediately plans for swift global
distribution
kicked in
so
and she wrote this in 2020
and that was pretty close if i'm not
mistaken to the
exact take all right so we won't call
her a prophet will we no no
just someone in the know yeah
in the summer of 2022 the other major
crisis of our age took a turn for the
apocalyptic climate breakdown finally
landed in the developed world testing
the resilience of social systems
now modern is very interesting that you
can predict the time when climate
catastrophe will strike exactly when
super droughts
and super rainfalls
and other catastrophes will strike at
the same time
what if you have a button to control
those things
[Laughter]
the midwestern usa
a severe drought wiped out crops that
supplied one-sixth of the world's grain
output so is there here an
idea that is being planted of famine
definitely
and it's linked to climate change
people woke up to the need of
governments to form coordinated response
to climate change and direct global
fiscal stimulus in support of a green
economy
that's a universal issue
a new concept of a healthy green deal
emerged in which climate targets and
well-being targets were seen as
complementary and required both supply
and demand side policies
the concept of social infrastructure
became
as important as physical infrastructure
those are all buzzwords
that are being branded around
particularly in jesuit circles
and so we stand here in 2023 the same
people but in a different society covet
19 convinced us we could not go back to
business as usual
the world has embraced a new normal
that ensures public private
collaboration as driven by public
interest not private profit
now modern
public private collaboration
together with government
collaboration is a form of fascism
and that's like you always said the main
objective of the jesuits and i find it
so interesting that
joe biden
is accusing the gop constantly of a form
of fascism
it's this double blind that's going on
yes they're playing a wonderful game
the covet 19 pandemic took so much from
us and lives lost and livelihoods
shattered
but it also presented us with an
opportunity to reshape our global
economy and we overcame our pain and
trauma to unite and seize the moment
to secure a better future for all it was
the only thing to do
now martin this sounds
all very well it's like building
a kingdom on this earth yeah well if you
can use their terminology building back
beta all right they want this complete
by 2023.
not much time
left do you think that they have a
speed train
agenda well there's
an interesting that there's so many
dates popping up
they must be careful that they're not
going to be
labeled as time setters no no that could
be very dangerous they have to watch out
for their time setting
so map released august 25
2022 and this is intensity of droughts
yeah she mentioned
the midwest and all of that and
according to this
it's everything that's red
or black
is extreme
so the only place that wet seems to be
the great legs
[Laughter]
all right so this is what they are
saying
and basically that is what she predicted
the summer of 2022. yes
so this is a reality all of a sudden
bang on time
it looks like
germany could have designed this
schedule because when they say it's
going to be at this moment then you can
be sure
then it'll happen
so let's go to europe
20th july 2022 brussels lays out eu gas
crisis plan ahead of the coming winter
now we've just had a summer disaster
they are predicting a winter catastrophe
yeah you've got and we'll see a little
bit later as well so you've got all
these droughts
but what is this extra factors that's
also leading to an energy crisis
so the european commission proposed on
wednesday 20th of july introducing a new
target for eu countries to temporarily
reduce by 15 their gas consumption
with the possibility of the gold
becoming legally binding in case of
emergency
so we have to be proactive we have to
prepare for a potential full disruption
of russian gas
and this is a likely scenario said
european commission president ursula
from lyon
what i find interesting
is that when the trump administration
was in power
donald trump
warned europe and particularly germany
that they were too reliant on russian
gas
and the germans decided to ignore him
so this is sort of uh like i told you so
yes and
this is this is also
maybe a plan to gain some
um
favor favor
in with donald trump okay so this is all
very interesting double blind what if
you knew there was going to be a crisis
ahead of time
and you said there was a crisis so that
you could say i told you so so that the
pendulum can swing is that possible or
is that now purely
conspiracy well if you can't think like
this then you don't understand what the
bible is saying the prophecy tells us
this is what's going to happen
irrespective
of what the forces are that are driving
in you
one of the forces that
are actually involved or that is
actually involved
is the fact that the winds are being
loosened yes
we must not forget that that's a
biblical force yes that's not
a human
force yes
and to mitigate this disruption the eu
has tabled the communication for eu
member states titled save energy
for a safe winter
and outlining energy demand reduction
measures now if it's a very cold winter
especially with global warming it could
probably be a very cold winter
it's climate change
sorry
then we then we could have a situation
where people are heating their houses
and they can be to
they can be blamed for the calamity yes
so that it's never someone else it's
always the public that has to conform to
some particular
exactly and if you don't conform you are
an enemy to the common good because and
you don't love your neighbor yes that's
it
so this is all intertwined every time
because that's the same if you didn't
adhere to
certain regulations you were actually
you could be labeled as a murderer yes
isn't it interesting martin that one
volcanic eruption can put more carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere than the
entire industrial world can achieve in a
year
another turns off hot water with the eye
to winter gas shortages
this is just turning on the screws a
time of trouble such as never
was
now in the old days you weren't reliant
on all these public supply mechanisms
but today in the cities you are
now
so where would you not be reliant on all
of these public uh
maybe in the country
would it perhaps be wise to get out into
the country i think it can be wise
okay
so the german city of hanover has laid
out measures to cut gas dependency on
russia ahead of the winter period
heating will be limited in public
buildings with no hot water
and no lighting of public landmarks the
city will limit the period in which
public buildings are heated between
october and march with the maximum
temperature generally set at 20 degrees
celsius
martin 20 degrees celsius for me is
freezing yeah
to a european and a canadian
it's perhaps rather temperate and
pleasant
but
where we live
we pull out these things exactly
in storage areas and on public transport
that maximum will be between 10 and 15
degrees
heating more generally will be switched
off or lowered in areas where it is not
strictly necessary sports halls gyms
would also be asked to limit heating to
15 degrees
with no more warm water when showering
but i think country living sounds rather
inviting
there will be no more outdoor lighting
of public buildings museums and sites
with wider efforts to limit permanent
lighting inside buildings public
fountains will also be shut down
it sounds like our country
i wanted to mention that
we showed the last time as well we've
gotten used to this type of
yes i've been practicing this for years
so let's look at the energy crisis and
see what
we on has to say on the issue
so what is europe doing to stave off the
crisis it is slashing energy consumption
germany has switched off street lights
france has banned illuminated billboards
italy has extended the life of coal pie
power plants spain has limited air
conditioning at airports
germany is undertaking a raft of
measures
they include a ban on heating private
swimming pools a ban on heating at some
public buildings lowering the minimum
office temperature to 19 degrees celsius
and switching off most street lights
same story in france
in italy where elections are due in
september the authorities are treading
carefully their energy savings plan
includes steps like extending the life
of coal plants temporarily halting work
at factories and shortening heating
hours at workplaces
in spain which is not as dependent on
russian energy supplies the reserves are
being safeguarded in case the war spills
over
these four countries are not alone
they're joined by several others in
reducing energy consumption
like switzerland finland sweden denmark
the netherlands austria and greece
okay martin so it seems as this is going
to be
a universal phenomenon
with the western countries
apparently attempting to lead the way
now if you look at this banning banning
banning this and that
isn't that a form of lockdown yes of
course it's a form of lockdown because
you're saying you can't go to those
places and if you do go you better take
a torch because it's going to be dark
the precursor has been put in place for
the past two three years
and now it's just spilling over to all
the other plants
all right now when you look at all the
nations in the world
the driving nations
in terms of all of this in terms of the
activities the legislation
they seem to be europe and the united
states largely right
ten horns martin that's it
and the image of the beast and the rest
of the world following
yep is australia complying new zealand
complying south africa com trying to
comply over they've complied already for
quite a long time already the solution
there is just let the infrastructure go
to pot and then you don't have to worry
about switching it on
true
so that's how it works so let's just
look at this system again
remembering what the political system is
that the jesuits favor
fascism
we've always said not fascism
like in you know marching
in strict line etc
but
government and industry and partnership
for community
that is the definition of fascism
so here we have an article from the
world economic forum
and the world economic forum and the un
science strategic
partnership framework
uh martin partnership
now the un is that concerned with the
politics yes okay
and the economic forum is that concerned
with industry and economics
so if they sign a partnership
for the sake of the community that's
fascism that's it and
if you look at the date this was in 2019
interesting
just before
everything started to go haywire all
right so they've they've got all their
role players together
now in the middle ages you had a feudal
system
and the feudal system was uh
what rome really
liked
because it had to control
only certain aspects in order to control
everything
so you had your feudal lords
they were the aristocracy
they owned the land
and then you had the serfs
and they
occupied
what belonged to the feudal lords
and this is how the economy worked
they were given a certain amount of
autonomy in terms of what they did where
they lived but they didn't own anything
yeah and they were supposed to be happy
it sounds familiar doesn't it sound
familiar that's how it worked in the
feudal system
now today we don't have that aristocracy
anymore
we still have some of the titles like in
germany fun
so and so
or fun too if it now really becomes you
know elitist
but today that is gone
so who has taken the place
of the feudal lords
the corporations
so the corporations have now become the
feudal lords
and the multi-billionaires that run the
corporations
they are the new aristocracy
and what happened now
is in the past few years
they've gained a lot of
power yes because the rest of the
smaller businesses have
gone down all right now this partnership
has to be for the sake of the community
and let's take a typical example
you have a wildlife area and there are
indigenous people living there
then you develop that
government and industry together
and the community that still lives in
its same in the same way that it did
before
gets a benefit not the individual but
the community so that housing is
supplied etc etc and that is the system
and everybody thinks that they are
really part of the system but they have
no decision making capacity
so in this system a large corporation
will supply the dwellings for its
workers
and as long as you are employed by this
corporation you will be locked into that
feudal system
and that is a form of fascism
so we've just redefined it and brought
it into the modern times
okay so why did they create this so the
un
forum partnership was signed in a
meeting held at the united nations
headquarters between un secretary
general antonio guterres and world
economic founder and executive chairman
klaus schwab
to accelerate the implementation of the
2030 agenda for sustainable development
now martin we've heard
many a voice saying that this has to be
hastened yes
the
2030 is just a little bit too far away
people are saying no no we must move
towards 2027
2025.
so i find that very interesting but
let's not do any dangerous time setting
let's just say this is their agenda
the partnership identifies six areas of
focus
financing the 2030 agenda climate change
health digital cooperation gender
equality and empowerment of women
you know it's amazing what the impact of
climate change is on gender equality
even that is a
gender problem yes yes and it's racist
and it's probably because of global
is it cooling or warming it's climate
change oh climate change
education and skills now how much of
society does this actually entail all
all of it
all right so whoever is in charge wants
total
control exactly
to strengthen and broaden their combined
impact by building on existing and new
collaborations
so it's not a question of communism
where the one takes over the other
this is a social system based on fascism
so let's listen to this declaration and
see what some people think about it
this afternoon the secretary general and
klaus schwab the founder of the world
economic forum will sign him will
witness the signing of a memorandum of
understanding on a strategic partnership
between the un and the world economic
forum which outlines areas of
cooperation to deepen engagement between
the two institutions and to jointly
accelerate the implementation of the
2030 agenda
okay martin so that was the announcement
of what would happen so if plans are
falling into place
and remember the 2030 agenda has like
we've read it's got to do with climate
change and the implementation of these
measures so
and as we've said
the world doesn't take into account the
spiritual aspects behind the scenes
exactly so let's just go to the great
controversy just to enlighten ourselves
on that issue
satan
works through the elements also to
garner a harvest of unprepared souls
he has studied the secrets of the
laboratories of nature and he uses all
his power to control the elements as far
as god allows
does he use
his agents to do that too yes so you'll
have humans doing this for it
some of these angels will probably also
be involved
so when he was suffered to afflict job
how quickly flocks and heard servants
houses children were swept away
one trouble succeeding another as in a
moment it is god that shields his
creatures and hedges them in from the
power of the destroyer
but the christian world have shown
contempt for the law of jehovah
and the lord will do just what he has
declared that he would do he will
withdraw his blessings from the earth
and remove his protecting care from
those who are rebelling against his law
and teaching and forcing others to do
the same
so
those angels are loosening their hold on
the winds yes is this what it says
that's exactly so it can be
somewhat confusing sometimes if you say
there's this hype over
the climate change but there's also some
truth
in that it is
said
in the bible as well that the angels
will loose
the winds they will loosen the winds
so the guardian says
humanity faces collective suicide of a
climate crisis warns u.n chief
so are they
making this a prominent issue
everywhere you look
it's
if you watch a nature program
or you watch the news everywhere it's
prevalent
now in that previous statement that we
read
it was because they were neglecting
god's
directives
his commandments correct
so
might we find that they will move back
to their form of the commandments yes
legislation will be implemented
antonio guterres told ministers from 40
countries meeting to discuss the climate
crisis on monday half of humanity is in
the danger zone from floods droughts
extreme storms wildfires
no nation is immune yet we continue to
feed our fossil fuel addiction
it's interesting what is happening in
countries like pakistan for example
where half the country is flooded yes
and that's not an area that is so
readily flooded no and then you get the
other portions
that's normally quite weight
we've got droughts
we have a choice collective action or
collective suicide it is in our hands
wildfires raged at the weekend across
europe and north america
south
america machu picchu
archaeological site was threatened by
fire extreme heat has broken records
around the world in recent months as
heat waves have struck india
south asia droughts have devastated
parts of africa unprecedented heat waves
at both poles simultaneously
astonished scientists in march
in the uk an extreme heat wave
was issued with the hottest temperatures
ever recorded in the uk expected on
monday and highs above 40 forecast in
some places
so modern
this is hype
let's call it hype
okay martin
so here we have some interesting
articles this one from 1975
and there they said that it was super
hot 40 degrees and above
and climate change was not even a
talking point at that particular time
and then
you have this interesting
graph here it's been drier rainfall in
may june and july before past drought
zamatan the very worst droughts were in
1921.
martin they're lying to us let's put it
bluntly
they are relying on cognitive dissonance
that people who are around 20 years old
will not remember what happened in 1921
and neither will those that are 80 years
old remember what happened in 1921
and as long as they don't remember that
and they don't dig up these articles
they might be induced to believe
that this is totally out of the order
it's creating this hype
that they can get all their
laws and rules implemented
and why do they want these laws and
rules this is what we're heading for
right
so martin when they say on the bbc
europe heat wave outdoor events banned
in parts of france and they produce all
of this hype and talk about 40 degrees
we've just seen that this has been quite
a regular occurrence in the course of
history yeah and once again we move back
to
band
outdoor events band so that's
a form of lockdown that's
you see what i'm getting at yes
absolutely time they
showing you that they are going to
implement rules
and if you don't adhere to it
you are going to be against the common
good yes
now you can do this on any scale a few
years ago there was a terrific drought
in the cape
and there were severe water shortages
and water restrictions that were put in
place within one year that drought was
completely broken
now which one was the climate change the
breaking of the drought or the drought
you know what in even australia they had
that huge
drought and then the flooding but now
they also you know they put everything
towards climate change so this is also
like you say climate change because the
extremes are also correct and why did
they have to change their terminology
from global warming to climate change
because they couldn't sustain their
arguments
so if you think of it
since the flood of noah
climate change has been ongoing
do you know that we have climate change
four times a year
[Laughter]
it's amazing you know
here in southern africa around june july
all of a sudden we have global cooling
and then
in december january and february we have
global warming it's called winter and
it's called summer and sometimes the
cycle goes it's a little bit drier and
within a few years say five or seven
years it goes back up didn't they have
climate change then in egypt as well yes
a few years ago they were saying you
know the snowfalls are so much less in
europe
and then they had record snowfalls again
so
it's it's a cycle it's what happens in
nature but let's see what the media does
with it and uh let's see what
they have to say
for millions of europeans the summer of
2022 has been sweltering a dry spring
and hotter than that usual temperatures
have left several european countries in
the grip of drought
extreme heat waves and forest fires have
plagued france italy spain and portugal
for weeks
the uk has recorded temperatures over 40
degrees celsius for the first time
and rivers on the continent are drying
up in the netherlands and germany the
river rhine has dropped so low that
houseboats have become stranded and
commercial ships can't carry full loads
anymore
our final story is about climate change
scientists have tried explaining it for
years they've given lectures they've
published papers but none of it has
really moved our world leaders maybe
pictures will what you're looking at is
a reservoir in spain
84 empty you can see the paddle boats
and water slides abandoned nearby
aquatic life driven to death the reason
climate change spain had its hottest
july since 1961. some parts of the
iberian peninsula are at their driest in
twelve hundred years let that sink in
twelve hundred years
spain's medieval reservoirs ruins of
ancient villages bath houses and
churches are facing the impact of
climate change
the iberian peninsula is reeling under
one of its drier seasons in twelve 1200
years putting further strain on europe's
largest network of damned reservoirs
this medieval bridge was flooded in the
50s to create a reservoir in central
spain
now it's exposed again and sheep shelter
there from the relentless sun
if this is not an emergency i don't know
what is the pictures the data the
testimonies all of them hint at a
climate emergency in europe it is not
some distant threat anymore it is very
much here and as we prepare to enter the
winter season more questions remain
yes the heat will disappear but what
climatic shock will winter behold
iman that is one side of the picture
and
i remember years ago i gave a lecture on
on this kind of issue
and at that stage i was
still pretty much
in favor of the scientific way of
thinking
and
in the meantime i've come to the
conclusion that these cycles have
occurred many many times and we've shown
many climatologists on whatsapprov
are
really high up in this particular field
and they blatantly deny that what is
being said is actually taking place
or that the reasons why it is taking
place are what they say what they are
so here's another nice example of
particularly this i mean we've heard for
years that the great barrier reef is
under tremendous threat and that is
because of climate change so let's hear
what these experts have to say on that
issue
now you think that anyone who genuinely
cares about the environment would be
absolutely thrilled about the fact that
two-thirds of the great barrier reef
have shown the largest amount of coral
cover in 36 years surely they would be
happy about this outcome after all the
doom and gloom predictions of the reef
dying
but no the media is desperately looking
for any reason to predict present this
as bad news there are even fact checking
memes mocking the persistently wrong
climate predictions we've all seen over
the past 20 to 30 years i retweeted this
meme and posted it on instagram with
this simple question have the climate
catastrophes ever got a prediction right
you would not believe what happened next
i got this absurd
fact check
fact check inverted commas claiming the
meme appears to downplay the damage
climate change can cause coral reefs
by comparing two tweets
of course this activist article posing
as a fact check did not have a byline
the cowards pushing this nonsense just
want to scare the social media sites to
not even allow any dissent not even if
it's a joke so let's get a man who is an
actual scientist and he puts his name to
his work he's a marine physicist and
author peter reed thank you so much for
joining me tonight uh tell me what's
your reaction to the media reporting of
the data from the official
long-term monitoring program of the reef
showing
massive growth in coral cover
well that wasn't a fact check that was a
fat twist and really all they said when
you actually read it is you've just got
to believe the experts the experts still
say that the reef is doomed
uh and the reason that they sort of
managed to get to was because now we've
got too much this supposedly fast
growing corals that takes
five to ten years to grow and they sort
of ignore the fact that they've been
telling us we've had four massive
bleaching events in the last six years
and this is the sort of coral that's
grown back
and that now because we've got too much
of this coral we're now even more
susceptible to the climate change like
we've had in the last five or six years
so there's a sort of circular argument
here that just doesn't work
so martin
if you
persist in telling a narrative over and
over again
irrespective of any counter-arguments
your argument will prevail
especially if you use the media that's
it because the media is the
all and end all
because if the climate scientist says
against the media then he's a conspiracy
theorist absolutely then he's a
conspiracy theorist so
let's just see how far this will go
so
irrespective of whether it's true or
whether it's not true that's not the
point
the point is things are going to move in
a particular direction and somehow
rome must be involved because the first
beast is going to
be worshipped
how do you worship the first beast by
obeying its dictates
so here's an article from earthbeat
from july 2022 african youth deliver
environmental demands to bishops
at lauda to see meeting
martin has laudato see a religious
connotation
definitely it's the encyclical
by the pope
about the climate
and all the governments are on board
using the name
and sooner or later
something's going to happen by popular
demand so here's the youth
asking
the youth demands were delivered to
bishops meeting as part of the 20th
plenary of the association of members of
the episcopal conference of eastern
africa
a regional grouping of bishops from
eritrea ethiopia kenya malawi south
sudan sudan tanzania uganda and zambia
the nine-day meeting held in dala salaam
tanzania is focused on the theme
environmental impact
on integral human development
through the lens of france's 2015
encyclical lauda to see on the care for
our common home
isn't it interesting what lens they use
yes they also propose that bishops
create laudatu sea clubs along with a
lodatosi fund
to lead community projects including
during the season of creation
september 1 to october 4 and on an
established low darto sea day
i wonder whether we could have a weekly
laudato c day wouldn't that be nice i
think it's on the books
we are calling on our bishops to instill
the spirit of care for creation to the
members of the church and to actively
participate in loudout to see
implementation
the catholic youth statement
said
we want implementation you of a papal
decree that's it and you you asked the
question or you made a point that by
popular demand isn't this popular demand
this is popular demand
here is uca news this is the union of
catholic asian news it's also from july
2022.
francis the pope who saves the creation
i wonder what we would do without him
as we see the ecological disasters
caused by climate change we must heed
pope francis's call to save the planet
now we don't have to read about his
encyclical
etc but the point is
the whole world
wandered after the beast
wondered if you look it up
means to wonder to admire
are they admiring him yes
oh for sure and it includes not only
christians now tell me is that a
fulfillment of prophecy yes
pope francis urges world leaders to act
on extreme weather
so in a message on thursday for the
world day of prayer for the care of
creation he urged nations to confront
climate change with the same attention
as global challenges
like wars and health crises saying
global warming hurts the poor and
indigenous populations the most
this of course is one of his favorite
mantras
because it gets the attention of the
masses always
in the first place it is our sister
mother earth but when i read that i get
slightly nauseous now extremely nauseous
but i will curtail
my feelings
and she cries out pray to our
consumerist excesses she weeps and
implores us
to put an end to our abuses and to her
destruction he wrote
he's a very flowery writer
cardinal michael cerney a canadian
jesuit who runs the vatican's ecology
and development office said all new
exploration and production of coal oil
and gas must immediately end martin
jesuit has just spoken no it's going to
be well
is europe already cutting down
yes is south africa in
trouble yes but what excuse do they use
a war
all of but their plan is being
implemented it doesn't matter what
excuse they use
and existing production of fossil fuels
must be urgently phased out tony added
now martin
i find this fascinating we have a jesuit
pope
we have a jesuit climate
person over here
and we have governments dancing to this
tune
always look at the result that's it
now martin if the pope could bless all
our rivers
wouldn't that curtail drought and the
falling water level of the rivers
probably could according to them so
let's see what he has done about this
issue
bless all those who will enter into this
water and use it
protect them in their daily journey to
you
and in the service to others
and the car of all creation
father by the sin
of the holy sprinkling
the remembrance of our rebirth from
water of the spirit
as we await new heavens a new health
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
one i don't have much to say on the
issue
unless i say something
that could be misconstrued have you
something to say
well i have to get myself together now
but on the article that we read that
sister and mother earth it's actually
pantheism of course it's panthers and
this what we just saw
it's the same as idolatry and pantheism
correct
so
is this the worship of the true god
no definitely not all right now is it
leading to
there's an article from the 27th of
august 2022
and
you know martin
just to get it back to a serious note
we show these articles continuously
the point is they don't stop
and that is so important because you
cannot get bored with this because
unfortunately this has to show you
this is planned and it's not going to
stop and you have this notion
that if you repeat something over and
over and over again eventually it gets
lodged in the human psyche
so it's not something that they mention
and then back off
no
it's actually picking up steam
so here is cne news
and it says sunday is for prayer not for
shopping says the polish government
the polish government is organizing a
round table with triad industry
representatives about the sunday closure
now remember this is a country that
already has sunday legislation in place
but their voice in europe is becoming
more prominent yes very more prominent
and
it is a warning
anybody else in the way that they might
not adhere to the rules yes and this
country poland is actually a very
important country
strategically
let's put it this way because they are
the barrier between russia and the rest
right
so especially marlena malaga the
minister of family stresses that the
sunday as the most important day of the
week is for family and prayer not for
spending in the store
since 2018 poland has a ban on sunday
trading
writes notes from poland this
legislation was introduced by the
governing national conservative law and
justice party
this ban was supported by the solidarity
trade union and the roman catholic
church
now the trade unions will play a part in
introducing a time of trouble such as
never was
the family minister underlined that all
businesses should comply with the sunday
trading ban this week the roundtable is
expected to take place early next year
are they tightening the screws yes so
obviously they turned a blind eye here
and there but that is coming to an end
you see these
stores found some loopholes for instance
they
had a
reading you could go into the store and
read but then you could also buy
something
so they they just found some loopholes
but now they want to get rid of those no
loopholes is sunday law legislation
going to be very restrictive
now in our previous one we showed
that the evangelicals in the united
states of america
were saying that we have to
get the power back
and people will have to get used to
living in a christian society under
christian laws
didn't they say that that's their whole
mantra that's where they're heading
now when they get the opportunity to do
that when they implement that
are they going to let go easily after
all these years of taking a back seat no
they're going to latch onto it and not
let go
these laws martin are going to be
draconian
have they practiced draconian laws in
the last few years yes
exactly lockdowns
coercion
all of it's been impacted have the
churches joined governments
in this venture exactly some of them did
yeah church and state
and that's a terrible thing that that
happened and it's very sad that it
happened and it should never have
happened
so the bottom line
of all of this
is that we are heading in a particular
direction
the world
is preparing for a particular time and
they're saying we have a very short
window very small window of opportunity
and it is time to start listening
and the one that they want to listen to
is the man in rome
and they want to make an image to the
beast
that beast was restrictive
and enforced its legislation via the
state and image is another organization
that will do exactly the same
so if that was catholicism in the middle
edges that wielded the sword over
secularism
then in this case it will be
protestantism the evangelical world
wielding the sword over the civil
society and implementing laws to further
their
and if you think of it
the
left will be shouting on the liberal
laws that are being done with
like for instance roe versus wade
but all of them
will be fine with the sunday legislation
all of them will be happy because that
is climate length linked this is a very
clever agenda
and this is exactly what the bible
predicts when that image is set up
when an image is not like the original
it's not the same thing
so here you must have the evangelical
world as we've shown in the previous one
dictating to the government
religious laws and you better get used
to it
that's what they said
and they're going to be very very
restrictive
eventually leading
to
economic
disenfranchisement
and then
eventually leading to a death decree
you either comply or else
that's where it's heading
did
the first beast do that in the middle
ages exactly
so the second beast will do it in the
time that we are living in
and if people don't wake up
they will be swallowed up by these lies
because if you repeat these lies over
and over and over again eventually
people will believe them
may god give us wisdom let's pray
heavenly father
prophecy is fulfilling before our eyes
and humanity needs to be warned
they are thinking that they are fighting
for good causes
when they are in rebellion
against you
and against your law
help us to bring this message across
urgently
in jesus name i pray amen
[Music]
you